[Music]
I'm Matt see Andrea this is car
collectors I'm Eric Breslow and welcome
to my collection
this is the Breslow collection it's my
private collection of European and
special interest automobiles we have
about 25 cars in the collection a lot of
iconic sports cars European and each car
for me has to have a cool story the cars
that you have here are not only
beautiful but I know each one has a
really unique story to it why do you
call this the airforce one Steve Baker
well you know the guy that designed this
car Raymond Loewy he was an architect
and he designed the original color
scheme for the Kennedys in the 60s of
Air Force One and it you know the Air
Force one it's kind of a blue and white
and so this car is kind of a blue and
white scheme so it's kind of our Air
Force one we call it I'm a sucker for a
GT style car I like the long nose for an
engine style of cars this is one of my
favorite body style cars of all time
this color seems really kind of special
to me it's very 60s right very 60s
English it's called sable brown with
cinnamon interior this is actually a
rare car because it's got factory air
and factory power steering so it's very
modern car to drive you know the engines
beautiful but you got to hear the
exhaust note and hear this thing start
you start it let's do it
I can't believe how easy it starts it
sounds great this is a 1957 190sl
Mercedes people just respond so well to
this car you know people come in and
they gravitate towards this this cars
been on catalog covers and and it's been
in feature films so this is one of my
favorite cars because it works hard Erik
you have some amazing Porsches but the
car when I ask you about is this Alfa
Romeo right here this is a 1965 Alfa
Romeo Giulia sprint speciale what's
really cool about this car though it's
only had two owners and it's 38,000
original miles and that interior is all
original another great investment car if
you can find one exactly so you have the
Helms bakery truck every time I see it
it makes me hungry by the way but let's
check this thing out it's a 1936 Divco
twin coach get
come on let's go that's your gas pedal
obviously and this pedal is a dual
clutch and brake pedal so step down
halfway now you're out of gear and then
step down all the way and now you're
braking this was a bread delivery truck
and they would drive around the streets
of Los Angeles and pull their little pie
tin whistle to let people know that they
were in town and ready to serve bread so
go ahead and give two tugs your bread
has arrived all right thank you so much
this has been an absolute pleasure now I
hope you've enjoyed a sneak peek into
Eric bressler's private car collection
to see more subscribe to GQ calm and
watch more episodes of car collectors
[Music]